Übung 6 exzentrische Dehnung der
hinteren
Oberschenkelmuskulatur starten Sie mit
leicht gebeugtem Knie auf einem Bein
stehend und strecken sie ihre Arme zur
Seite halten Sie den Oberkörper gerade
und neigen sie sich soweit sie können
nach vorne strecken Sie das andere Bein
dabei nach hinten oben aus und versuchen
den Oberkörper und das Becken parallel
zum Boden zu halten der Blick ist dabei
zum Boden gerichtet
halten Sie diese Position für 3 Sekunden
und gehen dann in die Ausgangsstellung
zurück wiederholen Sie diese Übung 10
bis 15 Mal auf einer Seite mit einer
Pausenzeit von 3 Sekunden zwischen den
Wiederholungen wechseln Sie anschließend
das
Bein